[Music]
on this Saturday night the Canadian city
with the most coveted 19 cases the stark
projections as restrictions are relaxed
the last thing people want is a few
weeks from now being told okay we
loosened the rules and now cope is
spreading again should provinces rethink
reopening the economic outlook jobs lost
now could be permanent in the US Plus no
pool no problem it's like a fish out of
the sea basically a Canadian athlete
makes hay of her training and he broke
musical barriers now the big voice of
Little Richard is silenced
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us there is a warning tonight from
québec's Public Health Institute that
deaths could spike
if physical distancing measures are
lifted new projections show deaths in
the Greater Montreal area could rise to
a hundred and fifty a day by July and
new cases could soar to ten thousand a
day by June Montreal has recorded more
than 18 thousand cases of copán 19 and
over 1,700 deaths it's by far the
hardest hit municipality in the country
Quebec has already delayed its reopening
plans for Montreal until the end of the
month it's a dilemma that many provinces
may face in the coming weeks as more
steps are taken to relax restrictions
whether labeled too cautious or too
lenient as Abigail Beeman reports it's
all a balancing act
Ottawa's famed tulip festival now mostly
virtual but the National Capital
Commission had to admit our bad
promising to take down signs telling
people they can't snap photos in the
public parks it doesn't frighten me to
take a picture with a tulip and if it
frightens a person next to me they can
just wait their turn and take their
picture a flowery example of the
balancing acts under way as Ontario
announces it will reopen provincial
parks it's also so short on Frontline
help it's working to get school board
staff like custodians and psychologists
into long term care homes and hospitals
we are committed to ensuring that their
staff could enter safely can make a
difference could retain their own
benefits I don't think we can all stay
lockdown until there's a vaccine there
might never be one but I'm I'm worried
that people will move too fast again
that balance I understand the economic
pressures were all under and I
understand how much people do want to go
outside but we need to do it in ways
that we are sure are going to keep
people safe because the last thing
people want is a few weeks from now
being told okay we loosen the rules and
now Cove is spreading again and you're
all going to have to go inside for the
rest of the summer the Prime Minister
consistently careful not to weigh in on
any provinces
plan saying he's concerned about his
home province Quebec just as he is about
the rest of the country yet hard-hit
Quebec is the only province with a set
date to reopen schools reopening comes
with its own challenges
New Brunswick issued this detailed guide
including what to do if you can't keep
two metres apart there's some ways to be
creative can you put barriers up in such
a way do you have booths in your
restaurant that you know maybe if we put
up some a piece of plexiglass or or
something that raised that raised the
top of the booths little higher
businesses in other provinces feel
they've been given no specific guidance
this small Toronto hardware store
decided themselves they've let three
people in at a time plus curbside pickup
we feel that we can offer one-on-one
assistance and tell the customers about
the products or that they're coming in
and touching things as each business
tries to juggle safety with economics
- Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa
here's a look at the situation in Canada
tonight more than 67,000 people have
tested positive for Cova 19 and more
than 4,600 people have died Ontario is
nearing 20 thousand confirmed cases
adding more than 300 in the last 24
hours more than 1500 people have died in
that province Army and Navy is the
latest Canadian retailer shutting its
doors for good
all five locations in Alberta and BC
were temporarily closed in March but in
a statement the CEO claims the economic
challenges of copán 19 have proven
insurmountable just days ago the
family-run company marked its 101st
anniversary the u.s. lost twenty point
five million jobs in April the highest
in that country's history economists
predict some workers who were
temporarily laid off could lose their
jobs permanently and as Jennifer Johnson
explains some businesses may be looking
to workers who aren't vulnerable to the
new coronavirus economists say America's
already bleak unemployment numbers could
get even worse while April's jobless
rate was the highest in history experts
say May's unemployment level
could climb even higher hitting 20% may
it's gonna be another tough month these
are numbers are full of hardship and
heartbreak a report from Main Street
America a group that represents 300
thousand small businesses predicts the
pandemic will force 7.5 million small
businesses to close for good a
University of Chicago study shows 42
percent of those temporarily laid off
will never get their jobs back there's
no way that many of these that are
hardest hit in the food services
industry leisure and hospitality are
going to be able to come back to the
level of activity that they did prior to
the crisis unemployment is now at
fourteen point seven percent in February
it was three point five percent even
estates and businesses reopened the
future is filled with uncertainty for
millions of workers I'm basically at my
breaking point
worried nervous scared it won't go back
to business as usual for some big
corporations too some manufacturers may
use robots instead of people and social
distancing rules make assembly lines
less efficient I really think that we're
entering a new age when the ideas that
maybe worked well in the twentieth
century are not going to be viable in
the future where where technology just
becomes vastly more powerful u.s.
president Donald Trump is fighting to
keep his job two up for re-election in
November for three years he's taken
credit for America's strong economy now
all he can do is sound optimistic about
it quickly bouncing back it's gonna be
transitioned to greatness but experts
tell a different story what we're gonna
see is the economy move in fits and
starts and really struggle to recover
many economists predict it will be
several months but more likely years
before America's economy will be nursed
back to health
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
the US Canada border has been closed to
non-essential travel since late March
but that mutual agreement is set to
expire later this month
some premiers say it's far too soon to
even consider lifting cross-border
travel restrictions her Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson
with a former US ambassador to Canada
about their relationship with our
neighbors to the south in the time of
Cova 19 Mercedes Robin president Donald
Trump has made no secret of his desire
to reopen the American economy despite
the high rates of kovat 19 in the United
States and while the canada-us border
has been closed for seven weeks now
the agreement in place that closed it is
set to expire on May 21st that's less
than two weeks away and while the
Liberal government says there is no way
the border is reopening anytime soon
what happens if President Trump won't
negotiate an extension to the current
agreement and what happens if Canada
doesn't want to open up on Trump's
timeline I put that question to former
US ambassador to Canada
James Blanchard who's also the former
governor of Michigan do you think that
there is a potential risk that the
Canadian government runs afoul of
President Trump if they don't agree to
open the Canadian border when he wants
to open the American one this is
something the Prime Minister Trudeau has
had to deal with before and a lot of
Canadians are worried what might the
president do if we're not on the same
schedule yeah it's hard to know I mean
you know he's fairly abnormal
personality to say the least one minute
he attacks Canadians next minute he
talks about how great they are I would
look more to the Secretary of State
Pompeo or our Commerce Secretary our
people there look most of the members of
Congress Senate and House all the
governors consider Canada a very
valuable partner that needs to be
listened to and worked with not lectured
to or undermined and that's as far as
I'm concerned that's the reality
president is not often dealing with
reality whether he's recommending Clorox
disinfect yourself or foolishly labeling
steel from Canada it's a national
security threat we'll have more on how
what's happening south of the border
will affect us economically and
politically right here in Canada
tomorrow on the show Robin Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa the UK is imposing
another 14-day quarantine to stop a
second wave of Kovan 19 that is prevent
seasonal workers from traveling to work
on farms but the fresh fruit and
vegetables are ready to be picked and as
crystal commencing reports Brits are now
being asked to roll up their sleeves an
upbeat hard sell for an honest day's
work Brits are being called on to help
put food on tables and keep a
multi-billion dollar industry alive it
hasn't been easy it's not easy work
physically it's very demanding and if
you haven't picked lettuces or you
haven't picked asparagus before it tests
out muscles that you probably didn't
realize you have it Fitness is not a
requirement workers just need to be
available and virus-free border closures
because of the pandemic mean the usual
70,000 seasonal workers mostly from
Eastern Europe aren't available response
lots of good success stories of Brits
who volunteered for these jobs I look
three children so I need to be working
I'm self-employed as a bricklayer
relying on locals to ensure the food
supply is really the only option at this
point it's not as if the UK can turn to
one of its neighbours and asked to
import produce because at this point
with the lockdown on the pandemic most
nations are in the exact same position
in Mexico assembly line workers are
being shifted outdoors sent into fields
with masks to pick berries so they won't
rot and go to waste
then there's the issue of buyers with
restaurants and cafes closed in many
countries around the world demand has
plummeted some American communities have
resorted to giving away potatoes and
litres of milk Canada is looking to hit
pause on some of these issues the
government unveiled a 252 million dollar
aid package for the agricultural
industry the reopening of markets
however could also pose challenges
there's still a lot of nervousness
amongst growers because as hopefully we
move out of lockdown and the recovery
program starts and people start to
return to work you know that will start
to lose people from farms in a normal
season farmers faced many uncontrollable
factors the pandemic poses a new
long-lasting challenge for producers
right around the world
crystal gyum Anson Global News London
spring planting is taking a pause this
weekend in parts of eastern Canada check
out this whiteout in Fredericton this
morning a polar vortex is causing
temperatures to plunge Toronto came
close to setting a new record with a low
of minus 4 point 7 the winter like
weather caused the snowbirds to postpone
the operation inspiration flight over
southern Ontario today the team tweeted
we said snowbirds not snow it's a much
different story on the other side of the
country
Vancouver beaches are busy with
temperatures climbing above 20 degrees
other regions of BC are closing in on 30
degrees this weekend provincial health
authorities are reminding people that
congregating in large groups is still
not OK and to maintain a safe social
distance coming up sidewalks and social
distancing how city planners are
changing spaces
you
in most cities sidewalks are not set up
for social distancing yet that will be a
norm for some time to give people some
space cities like Madrid Seattle and
Toronto are turning roads into walkways
Reggie Cecchini explains social
distancing social distance social
distancing easy to say much more
difficult to practice for decades the
car has been king of the urban jungle
but kovat 19 has now ended that reign
when we close our streets to cars we
open them up for amazing possibilities
streets now lay bare while sidewalks are
teeming with activity posing a challenge
how to put distance between all those
feet why are the pedestrians in the
leftover space the pedestrian should be
in the primary space to slow the spread
we have had to spread out but that is a
hard thing to do when space is a rare
commodity which can touch this street
signs trees and people all pose problems
for anyone trying to keep a safe
distance 6 feet or 2 meters requires a
lot of room people all over Oakland are
walking and biking in streets that they
normally would not in Oakland the
sidewalks have spilled out onto 119 km/h
/ you have less traffic you need streets
open so people can walk cities are very
quickly adapting how the streets are
used from primarily being really for
cars to being places for people which is
what we need more than ever and as
economies come back online allowing for
the safe use of space is critical lines
for Toronto businesses will form in
empty curb lane parking spots while some
European restaurants are now serving
sips and snacks in streets and plazas it
is part of this new normal and we're
gonna find that in in many places we're
going to have to readjust Kovach 19 has
proven that City Planning is sometimes
based on old ideas but a city is only as
healthy as the pea
who call it home thinking about public
spaces not as something that's frivolous
but rather as essential to creating good
urbanism and great density that's where
we need to go in the future and with
social distancing playing a large role
in that future a safe space to practice
it is all but essential Reggie Cecchini
Global News Washington
still ahead how Canadian athletes are
training with no gyms
with gyms and fitness centers closed
this pandemic may have you feeling out
of shape home workouts may cut it for
some but for Olympic level athletes the
stakes are too high to lose strength
that's why one Canadian is pooling all
of her resources to prepare for Tokyo
2020 1 Mike Jolie explains 2020 was
supposed to be the year Kira Christmas's
lifelong Olympic water polo dream came
true
qualifying for Canada is just like the
best feeling than the pandemic hit and
the Tokyo Olympics like all major
sporting events were canceled and around
the world thousands of athletes were
left like the rest of us stuck at home
and just like us they had to make do
with what they had
so Toronto Raptors Serge Ibaka did
sprints in his condo Canadian softball
player a makar bench pressed her bed and
Mitch Marner of the Toronto Maple Leafs
played keep-away with his dog the
athlete at home workout can get a little
weird too swimmer Brent hayden used
toilet paper rolls in place of weights
and gymnast max Whitlock used a couch in
place of a pommel horse which made no
sense because he also had a pommel horse
outside but arguably none went so far as
cure Christmas who was desperate to
avoid taking a step back in her training
like you lose your shape as an aquatic
athlete so fast that it's it's a little
scary thinking how long we're actually
going to be out of the water it's like a
fish out of the sea basically what she
needed was a pool but none of the
above-ground models were deep enough to
allow her to tread water
so the Christmas's went shopping for hay
bales and began construction on a pool
for the prairies well I will say for
sure that we've always kind of been a
little bit crazy crazy are they just
creative because now Kira can continue
her training
although if the water was any colder it
would turn dice um I think a lot of
people were just kind of shocked at the
like lengths that I went to get a pool
no they're not
but that's why she'll be an Olympian
microlight Global News Toronto up next
Little Richard's legacy the kingdom left
behind by the king of rock and roll
before there was the tiger King
Siegfried and Roy were at the top of the
big cat kingdom today the entertainment
world is mourning one half of that
dynamic duo Roy horn passed away
yesterday from complications related to
Koba 19 horn and longtime partner
Siegfried Fishbach er were renowned for
incorporating white tigers and other
large cats into their magic act they got
their start on cruise ships and later
became one of the longest-running acts
on the Las Vegas Strip Roy horn was 75
the world is looking back at the life
and legacy of little Richard a rock
legend whose hits inspired a generation
of musicians from the Beatles to the
Rolling Stones little Richard is labeled
one of the founding fathers of rock and
roll he was flamboyant and vocal here's
Eric Sorensen
[Music]
if rock'n'roll was a music revolution in
the 1950s as much as anyone Little
Richard
led the rebellion more than Elvis or
other artists Little Richard's shocked
conservative America black ostentatious
glittery no one had seen anything like
him I was crazy and my cousins thought I
was a kook
his whaling energy that drew from gospel
and the Blues won over white kids and
black that and the suggestive lyrics of
a song like 2d fruity saw his music
banned in parts of the segregated south
they didn't want the white kids to
listen to black music but they did
listen and no one could take their eyes
off him he left music for a while to
become a preacher but his influence was
seminal he inspired the likes of Mick
Jagger James Brown broad Stewart and he
influenced one of his own opening acts
called The Beatles
although he loved that another Beatle
Ringo Starr is among the music icons
honoring Little Richard posting one of
my all-time musical heroes beach boy and
innovator Brian Wilson said he showed us
all how to rock and roll and Spike Lee
called him one of the true creators
Little Richard was featured in a spike
Lee add the turn spike into Michael
Jordan for years he felt his
groundbreaking impact wasn't fully
recognized
Little Richard once stole the show at
the Grammys and yet Little Richard was
in the first group of inductees in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in 1986
unblessed I've stood the test
Little Richard sang into his 70s he was
fearless and he was an original Eric
Sorenson global news and that is global
national for this Saturday I'm Robin
Gill we leave you tonight with a little
more of Little Richard thank you for
watching good night
[Music]